من الخليل سيد عادل شديد الباحث المتخصص
في الشان الاسرائيلي عن وضع الحكومه
الاسرائيليه هل كانت تريد الوصول الى ما
يجري في هذه اللحظات ان تقوم بعمليات طبعا
فصائل المقاومه وهي ترد بالطيران لو لم
تكن تريد ذلك لما تركت الشيخ خضر عدنان
يلقى هذا المصير ونتجنبت هذا الوضع هل نحن
امام حسابات لدى الحكومه الاسرائيليه ام
كما قال ضيفي الدكتور مهند قبل قليل هو
ضعف في اداء هذه الحكومه
يعني
صحيح ان الحكومه الحاليه
فشلت في تحقيق كل الاهداف اللي اعلن عنها
او اللي اعلنت عنها منذ تشكيلها قبل اربع
شهور وكانت اربع اهداف
انهاء او ايجاد حل للمشروع النووي
الايراني ثم اتفاقيه سلام مع السعوديه ثم
تحسين الوضع الامني الفردي والقومي ثم
معالجه غلاء المعيشه لم تفلح ولم تنجح
الحكومه الاسرائيليه في تحقيق اي من هذه
الاهداف ولكن اليوم الازمه لم تعد فقط
ازمه الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليوم في ظل
الحروب الحاليه
والتطور نماذج الحروب
القدرات والامكانيات التي تمتلكها
الفصائل
والقوى الفلسطينيه والقوه المقاومه
بالمنطقه تختلف عن السابق بمعنى انه صحيح
انه اسرائيل في ازمه داخليه وفي ازمه
اقليميه ودوليه وفي وما في شرعيه
اسرائيليه للذهاب باتجاه حرب ولا هنالك
اجماع ولكن المتغير الاهم بالحسابات
وبطريقه التفكير الاسرائيلي انه هل الحرب
نفسها هي مجديه ومضمون ان تكسبها وان تحقق
اسرائيل انتصارا واضحا قادره على تمريره
امام المجتمع الصهيوني وامام اعداء اهلهم
نحن الفلسطينيون والعرب بالتاكيد هذا
المتغير المهم اليوم اسرائيل مقتنعه سواء
كان رئيس سنه ياهو وهو اكثر رئيس يدرس
تماما وبشكل دقيق الحروب ومدى جدوها
وكلفتها اليوم اسرائيل باتت مدركه تماما
انه عصر حرب العام 67 ان تحتل اكثر من 80
الف كيلو متر من اراضي جوه العربيه بساعات
هذا الموضوع هذا المرحله انت هت ان تصل
الى قلب العاصمه بيروت كما حدث بال82 هاي
المرحله انتهت اليوم اسرائيل تعلم وتدفع
اثمان كما ندفعها بالحروب بالتالي المتغير
سيد عادل اذكر بالخبر العاجل نقلا عن
مراسل الجزيره عن سفارات الانذاله التي
تدوي في مستوطنات نير عوز ونيرم عند
المنطقه الوسطى المتاخمه لقطاع